it is symbolic and significant the first
time serving U.S president has walked
the picket line with striking workers
you guys
save your
yard will be back in two
I've made a lot of sacrifices gave up a
lot and the companies were in trouble
but now they're doing incredibly well
and guess what you should be doing
incredibly well too
the White House likes to portray Joe
Biden as the most pro-union pro-worker
president in history
the workers we spoke to say they want
more than a photo shoot and support it
was great that he's coming out here but
anybody come down here and talk we want
to see some results I say we're asking
for exactly what we're worth we're doing
a hard job and we should get what we're
worth
workers at the big three car
manufacturers walked out when their last
agreement expired
they're looking for a 40 rise over four
years better retirement payments and
guarantees over jobs as the industry
switches to electric vehicles if
everything is held constant uh and the
growth of EBS does represent a threat to
employment in the U.S Auto industry it's
a big surge over the next uh seven to
ten years we could lose upwards of 75 to
100 000 jobs that's a big share of Auto
employment Joe Biden has to walk a fine
line here he wants to show support for
the workers on the front line of this
dispute but he also knows that an
extended strike will cost the U.S
economy billions of dollars and he plans
to run on the strength of the economy in
his re-election efforts also his biggest
Republican rival Donald Trump will be
here in Michigan on Wednesday trying to
win the support of the same Auto Workers
the companies say they've made record
offers to the unions their sign of
movement but not enough to get a deal
the White House says it's staying out of
negotiations but it isn't as reluctant
to show which side it favors Alan Fisher
Al Jazeera Detroit
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera